me présente je m'appelle céline mondon
et je suis directrice d'accueil de
loisirs périscolaire et alors là je vois
que vous êtes tous jeunes
vous n'avez pas d'enfant je pense alors
je vais être obligé de vous expliquer un
petit peu ce que c'est avec le
périscolaire ce doit pas vous parler
alors en fait c'est simple les enfants
une fois que vous les avez vous les
mettez à l'école et avant l'école
pendant le temps de cantine et après
l'école
ils sont au périscolaire c'est plus ou
moins un mode de garderie pour les
parents c'est vachement moins cher que
la nounou et c'est moins fatigant c'est
cool et est en fait sur ces temps
périscolaire il ya des animateurs qui
vont proposer des activités aux enfants
et moi je suis en charge de ses
animateurs donc au total à un animateur
peut travailler de 1h un maximum cinq
heures par jour
et moi j'en cadre une équipe de 40
animateurs qui s'occupe d'environ 800
enfants
voilà donc quand je suis devenu manager
j'allais enfin réaliser ma légende
alors vous connaissez peut-être plus ce
slogan mais à l'époque c'était le slogan
de systèmes réaliser votre légende et
donc première année j'étais prête à
réaliser ma légende et j'étais prête à
devenir manager donc jean dausset la
vaste de manager très fier de porter mon
mot de tailleur et la première année bah
ça a été un petit peu difficile pour moi
puisque je me suis retrouvé à faire plus
de licenciements que d'embûches car je
savais pas que c'était possible mais en
fait si et en plus quand je dis
licenciement je suis vraiment
extrêmement optimiste parce qu'en fait
c'étaient pas des licenciements
en fait c'était des abandons de poste
les gars il se barre des gelées envoyé
jamais et après je leur courait après a
essayé de les choper pour leur faire
signer leur fiche de démission pour être
d'écart avec la mairie autrement je me
faisais taper sur les doigts
donc autant dire que la première année
j'ai pas trop rigoler et du coup je me
suis dit bon céline on va se recentrer
et puis tu vas essayer de définir un
petit peu tes besoins et puis savoir en
fait comment tu vas faire là parce que
tu as signé un contrat il va falloir
aller au bout allez go
donc j'ai défini trois besoins le besoin
un truc super simple mais en fait j'ai
besoin d'avoir des gens qui sont là le
matin à l'heure et puis quand ils disent
ils viennent ils sont là alors ça paraît
évident mais vous tous qui allait
devenir manager vous allez voir en fait
ça les bains
donc voilà c'est la première chose à
voir des animateurs qui sont là en
effectif la deuxième chose c'est à
d'avoir des animateurs qui changent pas
toutes les semaines
parce qu'en fait le but c'est à minima
qui connaissent au moins le nom des
enfants dont il s'occupe ce qui n'est
pas forcément évident ou au moins les
lieux dans lesquels ils travaillent et
ça c'était important aussi et alors le
troisième point troisième besoin c'était
d'avoir des gens un minimum sérieux
parce qu'en fait on a des parents qui
viennent en nous donnant leurs gamins en
disant c'est la prunelle de mes yeux
prenez-en soin et le gamin le soir et
revient est gratinée ils sont larges
leaders gratiné qu'est ce que vous avez
fait vous avez mal fait votre boulot
donc il nous fallait dgac et les épaules
un peu solide pour savoir gérer des
enfants et du coup ça m'a amené à une
problématique que je vous pose
aujourd'hui c'est comment réussir à
trouver des gens qui veulent bien bossé
2 à 4 5 heures par jour au maximum
seulement les lundis mardis jeudis
vendredis en période scolaire payé à
coup de lances pierres au smig contrat
de vacation c'est à dire qu'ils sont là
ils sont payés ils sont pas là ils en
rien du tout et avec des responsabilités
voilà j'ai ça vous tente il y en a qui
cherchent un boulot non java n'hésitez
pas à me contacter et après en message
privé
bref du coup voilà je suis partie de ce
postulat et je me suis dit comme le
monde est bien fait je suis sûr qu'il ya
des gens qui doivent avoir envie de
bosser pour moi est avec moi on va
trouver et donc j'ai cherché et en fait
j'ai défini deux typologies de profils
première typologie qui est pour moi le
pain béni
du manager on a les étudiants merci à
vous les étudiants ils sont jeunes ils
sont dynamiques ils ont la pêche ils ont
des idées plein la tête ils sont hyper
créatif et en plus ils sont même pas
exigeant niveau salarial
parce que juste ils ont un peu de thunes
un petit peu à la fin du mois il paye 3
4 bières de plus ce samedi soir c'est
génial le jeudi soir pardon ensuite on a
les gens qui sont animateurs
professionnels il y en a donc pendant
les vacances scolaires il se tape des 50
heures semaine du coup pendant la
période scolaire
ils ont leur petit 20 heures par semaine
et ça leur fait à la fin de l'année un
temps plein ils sont contents après on a
des gens qui ont d'autres boulots à côté
genre un prof de sport il est coach de
sport le soir et la journée il va être
coach de sport avec les gamins au
périscolaire impeccable et puis après
donc là je vous avoue que ça remplit pas
le 25 % de mon équipe et après on
ad'autres typologie de personnes un peu
plus hétérogène on a les jeunes
déscolarisés
ils ont plus peur ils n'ont plus nulle
part où aller savent plus quoi faire
vient de taper à la porte on a les gens
sans aucune qualification qui trouvent
pas de boulot on a des gens qui ont une
vie perso qui était tellement prenante
qu'ils ont dû arrêter de travailler et
que là ils veulent réintégrer la vie
professionnelle mais à temps plein ce
serait trop compliqué pour eux donc ils
vont tranquille on a déjà en situation
de handicap
on a des gens qui peuvent toujours pas
complètement quitté leur domicile à 100%
parce qu'ils ont un enfant en situation
de handicap ou des trop grosse charge à
la maison
et puis on est les gens qui veulent le
récupérer l'allocation chômage parce
qu'ils ont plus de droits c'est aussi
autre chose donc la liste n'est pas
exhaustive mais en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que ça a créé une vraie
hétérogénéité et une équipe qui est pas
forcément évidente à gérer vous l'aurez
compris du coup je me suis dit que
j'allais quand même relever le défi de
manager et essayer de créer un
management avec une dynamique d'équipé
positive et puis arrivé à mon but
donc je me suis mis trois étapes donc la
première étape la constitution de mon
équipe je vais faire un tri sur le volet
c'est super important je vous le dis à
tous ce qui allait devenir manager plus
tard donc je vous disais j'ai une équipe
qui est relativement hétérogène avec
refile tous différents et des profils
qui sont aussi relativement fragile et
volatile
quand je dis volatiles gelé vu la
première année les gars c'est pas pour
est comme ça et qu'il y avait un truc
qui n'allait pas il n'était plus là donc
il va falloir que je crée mon équipe de
manière la plus équilibrée possible et
il va falloir que j'élimine les gens
nuisibles et vous allez me dire où s'il
perd péjoratif ça et pourtant c'est une
vraie réalité c'est à dire que si vous
mettez une personne nuisibles dans une
équipe ça peut vous en l'air
toute votre organisation et tout votre
tour votre dynamique ou tout autre votre
dynamique d'équipement du coup les gens
nuisibles j'entends par là alors on peut
pas les détecter de l'entretien
d'embauché mais au bout d'un ou deux
mois on va vite donc exemple l'animateur
qui tous les jours de 14 à 15 heures
amène la boe propose une pause pétards à
tous les animateurs et à 3h30 j'ai toute
une bande de zombies qui arrivent pour
s'occuper des gamins celui-là il est
nuisible direct on élimine l'autre
animateur qui a le téléphone greffé à la
main et qui me snapshots les gamins en
activité web beaucoup les gamins ça
c'est pareil c'est nuisible ça marche
pas encore d'autres animateurs qui vont
par exemple s'est amusé à créer des
clans a essayé de diviser les gens et
c'est à qui met la pagaille dans
l'équipe c'est pareil en élimine c'est
pas possible
autre chose sur la constitution de
l'équipe ben je vous disais on a une
équipe hétérogène
donc on part de l'hétérogénéité concret
on utilise toutes les diversités de
toutes les personnes qu'on a et on va
essayer de favoriser les échanges
l'entr'aide entre chacun pour arriver à
créer un tout homogène et cohérent ce
qui n'est pas évident mais ça fonctionne
la deuxième chose c'est une organisation
rigoureuse
rien n'est laissé au hasard donc on
utilise tous les outils que les profs
vous apprennent on a des tableaux on a
des schémas on a des fiches de poste est
en tout cas on crée une organisation
hypercard est hyper strictes qui va
permettre à chacun de prendre confiance
et de se sécuriser et ensuite j'ai
défini les besoins des animateurs donc
pourquoi il faisait beau c'est
finalement et de quoi ils avaient besoin
alors le besoin évident en c1 il ya des
besoins d'activité besoin de lien social
ou alors besoin d'argent ça c'est
l'évidence
et après il ya des besoins plus subtile
et dans le besoin plus subtile ce que
j'ai reçu ce que j'ai noté c'est le
besoin de confiance en eux besoin de
prendre confiance et alors à partir de
là je me suis dit bon moi j'étais
manager tranquillou avec ma petite veste
mais je peux pas rester que manager
là il faut que je donne confiance à mon
équipe alors je deviens manager coach
parce que j'ai aussi besoin de savoir
maintenant coach et mon équipe et alors
là j'ai pas j'ai pas réussi à prendre la
définition par coeur mais j'ai trouvé
cette définition du coaching qui me
paraissait intéressante je vais la lire
avec vous un parent coaching on attend
on entend par dont l'accompagnement
d'une personne ou d'une équipe
l'attitude que suppose le coaching et
l'attitude commune du manager ou du
consultant qui considère la personne où
l'équipe accompagnée à la fois dans son
fonctionnement actuel mais plus encore
dans son potentiel en train de se
réaliser
cette approche comporte à la fois une
philosophie une attitude des
comportements des compétences et des
procédures d'accords et donc à partir de
cette définition j'ai réfléchi un petit
peu à ce que je voulais donner à mon
équipe et je vous ai concocté une
recette et je vous le dis ce n'est pas
une recette de grand mère parce que je
ne suis pas grand mère mais c'est une
recette de jeunes professionnels que je
vais vous proposer
quand vous serez manager et vous aurez
une équipe qui a besoin de prendre
confiance en elles la première chose
c'est de créer un terrain vierge
donc moi je travaille dans une école
vous l'aurez compris un groupe scolaire
de 800 enfants et en fait ce que je vais
proposer aux gens qui arrivent c'est de
travailler sur un terrain vierge est à
dire que les gens y viennent avec leur
déception avec leur trauma y viennent
avec leur expérience passée qui sont
peut-être des fois douloureuse et alors
je ne veux rien savoir ce qui s'est
passé je ne leur demanderai rien et
je ne serai jamais ce qui s'est passé
avant tout ce que je leur propose c'est
de devenir un professionnel avec moi ici
et maintenant tout est possible
la deuxième chose c'est d'observer j'ai
besoin d'observer tous les animateurs
qui travaillent avec moi c'est à dire
que je vais vraiment passé du temps à
essayer de comprendre leurs points forts
et leurs points faibles et au delà de
les comprendre je vais les ressentir
je vais ressentir chacun d'eux
individuellement et à partir de cette
observation
je vais pouvoir identifier des
opportunités on met ce micro je vais
pouvoir identifier des opportunités
c'est à dire que je vais essayer de
capter les forces de chacun pour essayer
de leur confier des missions qui sont
adaptés donc là ça va vraiment être un
travail au cas par cas et je vous dis ça
parce qu'en management c'est important
le cas par cas et on va confier une
mission très différente à chaque
personne c'est à dire qu'une personne
qui va être plus créative et ben on va
le mettre sur pied une mission créative
une personne qui a peur d'être seul on
va systématiquement la faire travailler
en binôme
il ya des personnes qu'on va faire
travailler différemment sur différentes
tranches d'âge et c est à partir de là
je vous ai parlé d'une organisation
rigoureuse tout à l'heure une fois qu'on
a identifié les forces de chacun on va
aussi pouvoir affiner un petit peu
l'organisation et mettre un petit peu de
flexibilité pour que chacun amène sa
pierre à l'édifice ensuite je vais être
prompte et intraitable c'est à dire que
j'ai posé un règle une un règlement au
départ un cadre et dès qu'une personne
sortira du cadre je vais jamais faire
l'autruche et je vais recadrer les
personnes directement
on a souvent très peur quand on est
manager d'aller annoncer des mauvaises
nouvelles ou d'aller dire aux gens et
aux ce que tu fais c'est pas bien là
mais en fait c'est le plus important du
travail de manager je pense c'est de
savoir recadré en temps et en heure en
permanence pour que les personnes ne
prennent pas de mauvaises habitudes donc
il faut pas avoir peur de le faire au
contraire il faut foncer mais toujours
dans la bienveillance
ensuite je vais interviewer la
communication tout le monde en parle
depuis le début mais c'est toujours une
clé donc je vais tout le temps poser des
questions aux gens les personnes y
viennent de commencer une nouvelle
mission qui dit nouvelle mission du fa
tsy
c'est crevant quoi d'intégrer les
nouvelles informations et qui dit
fatigués relâche et alors là il faut pas
lâcher
donc il va falloir qu en permanence dès
que je sens une personne qui commence à
faiblir une personne énervé une personne
un peu en décalé je vais aller la voir
et je lui ai demandé ça va ça va ça va
alors c'est des petits ça va toute la
journée mais qui vont permettre un petit
peu d'avoir des infos et après le ça va
on va sur des questions un peu plus
ouverte
tu as passé une bonne journée tu es
contente ce que tu as fait l'être en
animation sata plus est ce que tu te
fais plaisir toujours oui d'accord est
ce que et voilà et petit à petit on va
greer grappiller un maximum
d'informations et toutes ces petites
questions informel vont des fois arrivé
à des entretiens plus formel et plus
professionnelle qui nous feront avancer
et enfin je vais entretenir le feedback
parce que tous ces animateurs je leur ai
confié l'émission ils les réussissent et
moi je suis derrière pour les féliciter
et pour dire bravo félicitations
là tu as bien fait le truc c'était super
et pour donner des axes d'amélioration
parce que c'est important et au pardon
et du coup je vous cache pas que c'est
un gros travail c'est vraiment un
travail de fourmi mais au bout de
plusieurs mois
on commence à sentir que l'ambiance
change on commence à sentir que les
animateurs sont plus présents à leur
travail
on commence à avoir moins de retards
plus de fiabilité de la part des
animateurs
on commence à sentir une certaine joie
d'être line une joie dans leur travail
une prise de confiance
une prise d'initiative est aussi
beaucoup plus d'autonomie et alors là on
arrive à un moment de grâce et on n'est
plus coach mais on devient ou c'est du
ramed sacré queue de cheval
j'y avais pas pensé excusez-moi aulas
et donc on arrive sur une relation de
professeurs elle est la preuve la
relation évolue vraiment et on ne se
retrouve plus dans une relation où les
gens ont l'impression qu'on est là pour
les contrôles et les diriger ou quoi que
ce soit ils sentent qu'on est là juste
pour les guider vers de meilleurs
horizons pour les faire évoluer
pour leur apprendre un métier et à
partir de là c'est gagné
on est dans une relation et de respect
et de confiance et de progression
continue et comme tout professeur il
faut se préparer à voir son élève partir
alors l'animateur que j'ai en face de
moi aura appris à un travail aura pris
confiance en lui à l'aura peut-être
passer une formation et elle partira
vers de nouveaux horizons pour trouver
un cdi temps plein waouh pour reprendre
ses études ou pour changer de carrière
mais en tout cas cette fois ci le départ
sera voulu souhaité anticiper des deux
côtés et lors du moment fatidique
on sera lui et moi des yeux dans les
yeux
dans le bureau un café à la main le
coeur sur la table et le sourire aux
lèvres quand il signera sa lettre de
démission
merci et je vous souhaite de réaliser
votre légende
[Applaudissements]